you get got someone like Bernie Sanders
and he wants to dream for you he wants
to give you your food he wants to give
you your healthcare and he wants to give
you your education he's not the guy to
solve your problems you are the guy to
solve your problems the libertarian
party is having its moment in the
presidential spotlight they have picked
former New Mexico Governor Gary Johnson
as their nominee for president the same
guy they picked back in 2012 who got 1%
of the popular vote but now he's polling
nationally around 10 percent for
president an office libertarians may or
may not even believe in that's because
the party stands for absolute personal
liberty and very limited government if
government is going to exist then it
needs to only be involved in protecting
our liberties that means no drug laws no
gun laws definitely no bathroom laws and
no taxes welfare or driver's licenses
should someone have to have a
government-issued license to drive a car
hell no whoo
swerve if you're libertarian
libertarians also believe in a total
free-market with no government
interference whether that be regulation
subsidies or bailouts so no way to the
poor but no way to the rich either so do
they ever see good in government
restrictions like I don't know selling
drugs to toddlers and yes you should not
be able to sell heroin to a
five-year-old
wait who booed that but the Libertarian
Party didn't choose that guy as their
nominee they nominated Johnson who along
party wishes wants to abolish the IRS
and student loans but does believe in
driver's licenses I mean you got people
that are blind that would be on the road
I think that would actually continue to
drive until they hurt somebody who's in
the base Johnson is kind of like the
Hillary of libertarians practical maybe
but too moderate for diehards see the
libertarian base doesn't exactly hashtag
feel the Johnson that's because he's a
former Republican who supports the
Environmental Protection Agency and says
he's okay that the government passed the
1964 Civil Rights Act I would have voted
for it they really do boo a lot with or
without the libertarian base if Johnson
keeps his poll numbers up he might have
a shot at getting on the debate stage
this fall which would be huge so given
the alternatives for president could you
feel the jump